the judge who's just sentenced those
three men all two prison sentences
described it as a conspiracy to enable
very Wicked sophisticated and violent
men to evade justice but essentially
they were doing between them was to
provide not fake passports but what are
known as fog passports so those are
fraudulently obtained
genuine passports
most villains who go on the Run have to
rely on stolen or forged passports and
of course they always run the risk of
being easily detected if they're stopped
if they have to cross borders where
checks are done or if they have to check
into hotels it's very difficult to go on
the run with a fake passport but these
were genuine passports and this
essentially was how it was how it worked
Anthony beard was one of the three he
targeted vulnerable passport holders
genuine passport holders they were often
people with drink or or drug problems
who were unlikely to travel the
passports had expired or it was claimed
that they'd been lost or damaged so
Anthony beard applied for replacements
for renewed passports and when they were
issued they were genuine he built up
store of them hundreds of them but then
when high-end criminals were on the run
and needed a new passport they would go
to one of the organized crime gangs that
Anthony beer was in touch with and order
one of these passports now Anthony beard
took a photograph of the villain on the
run and matched it from one of his
hundreds of stored passports so he found
somebody who owned that passport who
resembled the villain and then the
passport was applied for with the
villains photograph and came back with
the wrong photograph of course but it
was a genuine passport now this was an
investigation a long-running one
exposed by the National Crime agency and
we can hear now from Craig Turner from
the NCAA
the passport would be a Golden Ticket
whether you're wanted or whether you
want to go in and out the country uh not
seen by obviously law enforcement or by
borders it would be absolutely key to
running organized criminal Network
internationally and across borders it's
absolutely key to their business their
business structure
this has been a long investigation it
was two years ago that the principles
were rounded up in a series of raids
across Britain
um Christopher zetek was one of the Ring
leaders of this conspiracy and we saw
him arrested at his home in South London
but he was one of around a couple of
dozen people who were arrested that
morning the other two involved sorry
Christopher Z-Tech was jailed for eight
years Anthony beard the man who found
those what the police call identity
donors and persuaded them to let him
apply for new passports he got six years
and eight months and Alan Thompson who
even his own lawyer described was the
dog's body of this group he was jailed
for three years the judge said that the
fraud they committed subverted the whole
system of passport issue